[Music]
states of emergency and parts of Nova
Scotia on this Monday night the out of
control Flames threatening homes it is a
wind driven fire and the support being
offered to evacuees
the battle for Alberta on this election
day The Surge of Voters at The Ballot
Box there's a very
strong get out the vote machine going on
and the group claiming to control
Danielle Smith we are living in
a human society
who claims the Chinese government is
targeting another MP ceases had reached
out to me what the NDP is now pushing
for
[Music]
Edmonton
good evening from Alberta's Capital as
voters here choose their next Premier in
a closely watched election it will all
be decided tonight the United
conservative party is looking to win a
second consecutive majority the NDP is
fighting to repeat its Triumph of 2015.
the only time it's won in Alberta a
record number of people cast their
ballots in advance polls many more
casting their votes today if the opinion
polls and the analysts are right it will
be a tight race Heather York's West
explains the anxiety is high
[Music]
election day in Alberta but amongst
voters here in Battleground Calgary
there's a sense that things are very
different this time around I think it's
going to be a tight race and I work in
the social services so it matters I
think it really matters today what
happens so I think you have to exercise
the right whether you necessarily agree
with either party this is a riding that
could help decide the province's next
Premier the people here very aware that
across Alberta all eyes are on them it's
going to depend on Calgary a couple of
ridings there
as to which way it goes and it's toss-up
who knows I know it'll be close and I
think every like every vote counts
albertans are very engaged in this
election it's a very tight election
there's a very strong get out the vote
machine going on in both the UCP and the
NDP more than a quarter of registered
voters have already cast their ballots
ahead of voting day a record turnout for
the province's advanced polls
this political scientist believes a
higher voter turnout could be trouble
for the UCP if you have record high
turnouts in this election my hypothesis
would be that it would be folks who are
more likely to vote for the NDP because
UCP voters tend to be more
reliable or consistent in their voting
intentions with many writings polling so
closely the wait for results could
stretch late into Monday night I will
stay up till the result setting
I know it will be the right one and as
they say in politics the voters are
never wrong though of course that
perspective depends on which side you're
on
the election night headquarters in
Edmonton Heather it's still early what's
the mood like there
detail yeah what I'm hearing over and
over from the NDP Camp is that people
are hopeful but they are also nervous
this has been such a long campaign of
course the Writ drop May 1st but this
election race has been going on for
months since arguably Daniel Smith was
first elected as leader back in October
we know that Rachel Nutley herself
started the day with a run as she is
known to do and she plans to gather with
her family to watch the early results
come in it could however be a pretty
long night before we know all of those
results this is of course Rachel
notley's third Alberta election as
leader and many believe that if she is
not successful tonight it could be her
last so she does have a pretty high
mountain to climb if she wants to be
successful at reclaiming that job that
she lost four years ago to Jason Kenney
the NDP will need to flip 21 seats a
difficult task for sure but one that
many believe is possible all come down
to those key Battleground States in
Calgary and for now Donna we'll just
have to wait and see
all right Heather York Express NDP
headquarters in Edmonton thanks UCP
leader Danielle Smith is being tested in
her first election as the new leader of
that party and is someone who some
moderate conservatives are less than
enthusiastic about Mercedes Stevenson is
at the UCP election night headquarters
in Calgary Mercedes what kind of
campaign did Smith run
well this was really a campaign by
Danielle Smith saying choose what you
know insisting that she is what's best
for Alberta she'll stand up for Albert
and she says emphasizing her economic
record and try to capitalize on some of
that uncertainty around the NDP and
going after the ndp's record it was also
a case of Danielle Smith being seen less
and less on the campaign Trail at big
events as it went on I spoke to some
senior folks on the campaign who told me
they really thought support changed and
shifted for them when the debate
happened and that's because she didn't
re-articulate some of those very
controversial statements she stuck to
careful things that they know resonate
with voters and then they didn't have
her out very much and they really felt
that that helped they also told me that
they had a very strong ground game they
brought people in from not only around
the province but around the country to
make sure they get out the vote lots of
door knocking and they are relatively
confident Donna that they think that
they could win tonight although they say
you know they are aware Anything Could
Happen they think the path to Victory is
too narrow for the NDP they think that
the advance poll showed them that they
had a substantially more turnout for UCP
voters than they were expecting and they
say door-to-door while some candidates
told us that they were hearing that
people didn't want to vote for Danielle
Smith something we've heard on this
newscast too they were concerned about
her that people were willing to vote for
the party and that even in some cases
there was NDP signs on the lawn but they
claimed some of those voters would sort
of shyly whisper to them that they were
prepared to vote for Smith but they
weren't going to say that in public
they're relying on those votes to
believe that they can win tonight and
that those disaffected conservatives
won't just stay home despite some of the
very senior conservatives in this
province saying that they feel that way
or perhaps even willing to vote for the
NDP
good Mercedes if we zoom out from
Alberta but the outcome of this election
possibly be a gauge of how the
conservatives do federally will they be
watching closely
you know absolutely the conservatives
will be watching closely hoping that
this is a good omen for them keeping in
mind of course Alberta is very much its
own unique political Beast it's not a
duplicate of Ontario or any other
Province but there's a risk here for the
conservatives too Pierre pauliev
endorsed Danielle Smith and if she
continues to say controversial things
those will be used by liberals in attack
ads against him in the coming federal
election which could be 2025 but it also
could be a lot sooner than that
all right Mercedes Stevenson at the UCP
headquarters in Calgary thanks
well the political futures of both
notley and Smith are on the line tonight
lot notley has been leader of the
Alberta NDP since 2014 including four
years as Premier Smith became leader of
the UCP in October of 2022 after Jason
Kenney quit she took over as Premier
then with one group solidly behind her
it's called take back Alberta
no longer will Alberta ask permission
from Ottawa to be prosperous and free
it's Danielle Smith making bold promises
as the new leader of Alberta's United
conservative party but it's this man who
takes credit not only for getting her
there
conservative party of Alberta but for
ousting Jason Kenney he found it
according to him the United conservative
party of Alberta and we voted him out
David Parker is the founder of take back
Alberta take it back from the so-called
ruling Elite which it accuses of
censoring those who speak out and
restricting Freedom political scientist
Dwayne Bratt has been tracking their
rise he was able to mobilize you know 35
000 people which isn't a lot but was
enough to shape the leadership review
then he swung those same people that he
got to sign up for party membership to
support Daniel Smith in her campaign
Parker harnessed anger about the vaccine
mandates and pandemic restrictions and
has gone further we are living in an
anti-human society that literally
teaches our children that they are
disease on this planet
that the best thing we can do is
depopulate
you are the carbon they are trying to
produce he now claims to control Smith
through people in her office he was
standing in the room when she was
negotiating the Alta Court
adjustment
we asked take back Alberta for an
interview they declined Smith herself
has a reputation for saying what's on
her mind the community that faced the
most restrictions on their freedoms in
the last year were those who made a
choice not to be vaccinated so they have
been the most discriminated against
group that I've ever witnessed in my
lifetime maybe we get a cross-border
agreement with Ron DeSantis maybe he has
a little Zone in Florida that we would
be able to fly direct to all of it is
deeply worrying for lifelong
conservatives like Lee Richardson who
told me he's voting NDP for the first
time just outrageous statements no basis
in science but kind of populist views on
on matters simplistic answers to complex
questions how many other conservatives
do you think share your views on this
you know what I think a lot of them do I
think probably the majority do
but
they're not prepared to go as far as
voting for The NDP take back Alberta
avoids the so-called mainstream media
but Bratz says he's heard audio tape
from some of their meetings another take
back Alberta said you know if the NDP
win it's because they stole it we'll
have to get our guns and hunt them down
we don't know what's coming next
and I think that's that's concerning to
people in Alberta but also across the
rest of the country who are we dealing
with here
you can follow live coverage of the
election results it starts at eight
Mountain 10 Eastern on global news in
Alberta online at globalnews.ca and on
all of our streaming platforms
there's a major police operation
underway in Calgary after two people
were killed in a shooting that involved
the police one of the main routes into
downtown has been closed most of the
days officers investigate police say
they received multiple reports of a
large cube van driving erratic light
around 10 this morning officers pursued
it barricades were put up to stop it
from accessing the downtown
investigators have confirmed one officer
fired shots and two people are dead
Alberta's serious incident response team
has taken over the investigation
in Ontario a tragic crash has killed a
police officer and a school bus driver
near the city of Woodstock Police say
the collision between the unmarked
police vehicle and the school bus
happened just before 7 this morning no
children were on board the bus 35 year
old detective Constable Stephen turango
was killed police say they're not
releasing the name of the bus driver out
of respect for the family's privacy in
Nova Scotia thousands of people have
been displaced because of two wildfires
one of them just half an hour's drive
from downtown Halifax oh
this driver captured what it was like as
he drove to escape the fast-moving fire
in Hammond's planes Thick Smoke and
Embers surrounding the vehicle the
Wildfire raging on both sides of the
highway one of the largest fires is
burning in Shelburne County in southern
Nova Scotia it scorched thousands of
hectares and more than 400 homes have
been evacuated the second intent Talon
near Halifax has already destroyed
houses at least 10 homes are known to
have burned and there are reports that
number could be much higher
we could see the smoke just on the other
side of the trees and realized yeah
that's moving quick
um so so we packed up we grabbed a few
things and we left we were able to save
foreign
destruction
gusting winds in very dry conditions are
making the situation worse Callum Smith
on the fires and the race to contain
them
[Music]
Crews fighting from the air and the
ground as they battle the tantalon fire
go go go go go go go go the fire and tan
Talon is still estimated about 788
hectares
uh the one kind of good news story that
we're hearing so far from officials at
the site as as the mayor indicated
there's been minimal growth no injuries
have been reported but more than 16
thousand people have been forced from
their homes as of Monday afternoon
it is a wind driven fire
our fire service along with the
Department of Natural Resources is
working exceptionally hard against
challenging conditions and we owe them a
great debt of gratitude
together they have protected schools
seniors facilities and scores of homes
the fire started Sunday afternoon the
Danes are so imminent evacuations began
almost immediately the Nova Scotia
government offering 500 to any of those
evacuees while Ottawa vows support too
the federal government will be there to
support any ways we can as people are
dealing with some pretty terrifying
situations
officials say they believe the fire is
human caused given we haven't had any
lightning with more dry weather
conditions forecast a province-wide burn
ban is now in effect trying to decide
which building you have the best shot of
saving and which buildings perhaps you
can't save or you thought you could save
but the fire conditions were such that
you had to pull your people away for
their safety Callum Smith Global News
upper tantal and Nova Scotia
uganda's new anti-gay law coming up the
punishment members of the gay community
could now face plus the brutal assault
in Ukraine that sent children running
for their lives
this is a Saddle Dome in Calgary the
city that's a key Battleground in
tonight's election we're back from
Edmonton in a moment
children running for shelter in Kiev as
Russia launched a daytime missile attack
hours after its usual overnight
bombardments Ukrainian military
officials say all the missiles were shot
down and one person was injured by
debris the attacks come on Keith day the
anniversary marking that City's founding
there is international condemnation of
lawmakers in Uganda after that country
approved one of the harshest anti-gay
laws in the world the country's
President signed the so-called
anti-homosexuality act same-sex
relations were already illegal in Uganda
under this new law the penalty if
convicted is prison or even the death
penalty for those who were HIV positive
in a statement the U.S President Joe
Biden called the ACT shameful and says
his administration will reevaluate
American ties and Aid to Uganda a joint
statement by International AIDS relief
groups including the UN also says
uganda's progress on fighting HIV is now
in grave Jeopardy
a Canadian man has been extradited to
Thailand in connection with the killing
of a gang member in Phuket an Alberta
Court approved the extradition of
38-year-old Master Duprey last December
he's wanted for the murder of Jimmy
sandoo who was shot in February of last
year Sandhu was born in India and raised
in Abbotsford D.C where he joined the
United Nations gang and was deported to
India in 2016 for what Indian police
call serious criminality
[Music]
public inquire refresher ahead another
MP says she's been targeted by Beijing
you're looking at the walterdale bridge
in Edmonton we're back from the
University of Alberta in a moment
[Music]
in Ottawa MPS return to the house today
and calls are growing for a full public
inquiry into foreign election
interference and for David Johnston to
step down as the so-called special
repertoire former governor general
determined the public inquiry is not
needed because he says it couldn't be a
full public inquiry now another MP says
she was also targeted by Beijing turia
isri reports
the list of MPS briefed by Canada's spy
agency is growing ceases has informed
conservatives Michael Chong Aaron
O'Toole and now new democrat Jenny Kwan
that they have all been singled out by
the Chinese Communist Party Caesars had
reached out to me Kwan says she can't go
into details about how China is
targeting her only why the reason why
I'm being targeted is because of my
activism in support and to fight for
basic human rights opposition parties
return to the house and repeated their
calls for a public inquiry something
former Governor General David Johnston
ruled out last week the Prime Minister
appointed a family friend in Trudeau
Foundation member to investigate more
like cover up the conservatives can
continue to malign Mr Johnston despite
the fact that he has distinguished
Public Service which was recognized by a
former conservative prime minister and
Stephen Harper
Johnston plans to hold public hearings
into foreign election interference but
the new Democrats and conservatives
agree it's time for him to go the NDP
has introduced a motion calling for
Johnston to step aside a special rapper
turf Toria is read Global News Ottawa
political diversity next how tonight's
election could defy Alberta's history of
predictable votes
you're looking at the Peace Bridge over
Calgary's Bow River we're back in a
moment
[Music]
welcome back to Edmonton alness
provincial election day elections in
Alberta don't always attract so much
interest for decades this province voted
overwhelmingly conservative and there
wasn't much variation at the top from
1971 to 2006 Alberta had just three
premiers always conservative always men
always predictable in the last 12 years
there have been seven premiers nearly
half of them women one of them left
leaning and as Eric Sorensen reports
tonight Anything Could Happen
Alberta is changing the people and its
politics an urban rural divide
represented by two leaders who couldn't
be more different and want you to know
it Danielle Smith we can choose to go
backward with the NDP and Rachel notley
she can't be trusted to fix our health
care there's never been a two-way race
in Alberta this close and so bitterly
divided it really will tell us a battle
of what I call the the two albertas and
which one is going to come forward
there was a time when elections in
Alberta were the most boring and
predictable in the country one
conservative leader after another
and always men who won again and again
welcome to uh Ralph's World
but times began to change Ed stelmack
lasted just one term
a decade ago Allison Redford became the
first woman to lead Alberta as Premier
but conservative party Unity was
unraveling opposed by the Wild Rose
party led by Danielle Smith
the divisions soon helped Rachel notley
and the NDP score the most surprising
upset in the history of Alberta politics
I solemnly affirm
conservatives reorganized under Jason
Kenney the silent majority has spoken
but it didn't last and now Danielle
Smith leads a disunited party in a
province that's evolving we have a lot
more diversity
particularly in the Urban centers than
historically might have been the case
notley will almost certainly win the
urban vote in Edmonton and much of
Calgary but Smith and the conservatives
grip on Rural Alberta could tip the
balance a small margin that could take
Alberta Down's starkly different paths
within Canada Alberta needs stable
predictable capable leadership as
Premier notley clashed with but also
worked with Ottawa Smith is likely to
confront and test ottawa's jurisdiction
in Alberta this legislation will ensure
no government can increase your personal
taxes I think there'll be a lot less
drama under Rachel notley but only if
Alberta still mostly conservative has
changed just enough for those who are
really strongly conservative it may be
too far a walk to go all the way over to
the NDP but for others it's it's good
governance that they're focusing on and
not ideology whether Danielle Smith's
conservatives are re-elected or Rachel
notley's new Democrats win for the
second time in three elections Alberta
is no longer so predictable and its
elections no longer boring
Eric Sorensen Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday from Edmonton I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your Canada is the Alberta
legislature where depending on tonight's
results either Danielle Smith or Rachel
notley will occupy the premier's office
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you